hey 42 here in 2009 in a lonely desert
just above albuquerque
building developers uncovered a grim
scene
as they pushed a development into the
west mesa landmass
the construction of a shallow wall built
to deal with storm water
inadvertently brought something
horrifying
to the surface 11. decomposing bodies
all buried in shallow graves
over the course of several weeks the
police uncovered the graves each of them
spread out over a 92-acre stretch of
land
it took a further year to identify them
all were women between the ages of 15
and 32
almost all were hispanic and almost all
of them were prostitutes and
drug users one of the women had been
pregnant
and her fetus was with her in the grave
horrified by the discovery the new
mexico authorities
banded together with crack fbi profilers
and detectives
and set out to figure out what had
happened
but the result was less than they had
hoped for
try as they might they could not figure
out what had happened to the women
there were clues potential leads and
even suspects but
nothing concrete and to this day the
mystery has
never been solved and the serial killer
dubbed
the west mesa bone collector by the
press
is still at large the rarest form of
homicide the fbi defines a serial killer
as an individual who kills two or more
victims previously unknown to the killer
and who takes his or her time between
each kill in what seems to be
a modern phenomenon serial killers have
risen from the early days of jack the
ripper to becoming
a disturbingly common fixture in the
news and
the modern psyche dominating countless
movies tv shows and
novels in fact serial killers have
seemed to follow some of the largest
societal changes
of the last 400 to 500 years
those being the rise of urbanization and
its accompanying society of strangers
the rise of mass media and celebrity
culture
and a culture that's through its very
structure helps to
marginalize and disenfranchise the
psychologically vulnerable
whilst it's difficult to say with
certainty what creates a serial killer
all that is clear is that the modern
world is one of the most fertile
environments
for creating them and these killers
usually share
certain characteristics over a 25-year
period
forensic psychologist dr mike ahmad
and his students trawled through data on
almost 3
000 us-based serial killers and 10
000 of their victims what they found was
surprising
the vast majority of serial killers were
below the age of
30 and the majority of them kill for
enjoyment
31.8 percent or financial gain 30.1
almost half of their victims were shot
to death as opposed to the more bizarre
method of drilling holes into their head
and then filling them with acid as used
by jeffrey dahmer
following this 21.7 percent were
strangled to death
and 14.8 were stabbed it also became
apparent that
iq differentiated the killer's methods
with the most intelligent amongst them
using
bombs but in general most serial killers
are
highly unintelligent with an average iq
of 94.5
rather contrary to the pop culture idea
of
highly intelligent sociopaths also
despite the common assumption that they
solely prey on women
the split between male and female
victims was fairly equal
however if you're white and young then
you're by far
the preferred victim it's also
apparently
a very short step from serial arson
to hunting human beings but
perhaps most shocking of all is the data
on how many serial killers
just might still be at large
when for instance unsolved murders
linked by dna are considered
usually a hallmark of serial killing it
comes out at about
1400 or 2 percent of all murders
in the files consulted this has led
homicide analysis thomas hargrove to
believe
there are around 2100 serial killers at
large
in the us michael anfield
a retired police detective and expert on
serial murder believes the number to be
more like three
to four thousand disturbingly even
though the number of serial killers has
fallen to one percent of all killings
the lowest it has been in years the rate
of solved murder cases
has decreased also meaning that 40
of the time the killer remains at large
a lot of this comes down to linkage
blindness
where cases are spread between multiple
detectives and jurisdictions
but are rarely discussed across those
boundaries
this may be why serial murderers such as
samuel little
who have been linked to over 60 murders
have been able to be so prolific the
longer he remained at large
the more he continued to kill it is why
even today terrifying and disturbing
serial killers
still lurk amongst us for various
reasons uncaught and free
to roam what follows are some of the
most terrifying of all
uncourt serial killers in 2011
the new york state police were
conducting an investigation into the
death of shannon gilbert
her body had been found on long island
gilgo beach and assuming it to be a
single murder
the police looked for clues as to who
the culprit was but what they found was
far greater than they could have
ever possibly imagined near her corpse
they found a large grave filled with
four dead bodies
all female more searching discovered
more graves
in which lay six more dead bodies
including that of a man
dressed in women's clothing and the body
of a child amongst the graves were body
parts that once investigated
were found to be linked to unidentified
bodies found miles away
connected to crimes dating as far back
as 1996.
it soon became clear to all that a new
serial killer had been discovered
and he had been prolifically active for
quite some time
so they began to look for clues
they found that the killer's victims
were largely sex workers who advertised
their trade on craigslist
amongst whom was melissa barthelomy
after disappearing from her bronx home
in 2009 her parents immediately went to
the authorities
and sought some kind of help but
they were largely ignored it wasn't
until the family's young daughter
started receiving
unsettling phone calls from an unknown
number with a man's voice
saying i killed melissa
since then the long island serial killer
as he's come to be known
has been pursued with great energy by
the authorities and a number of details
have begun to emerge
chief amongst them is that the killer
has an in-depth knowledge of law
enforcement techniques
and a possible connection to law
enforcement
itself which would explain how
meticulous he is
and how effective he is at evading
capture
one suspect was former suffolk county
police chief
james burke he was reported to have
blocked an fbi probe into the long
island serial killer
during his employment as police chief
but
as yet the true identity of the killer
remains unknown in 2005
the decomposed body of a 28 year old
woman was fished out of a canal
in the jefferson davis parish of
southwest louisiana
she was a known drug addict who had
turns to prostitution in order to fund
her addiction
and her death was chalked up to being
another victim of the drug trade
but it wasn't within three months
another woman's body also a prostitute
was discovered in another canal
in 2007 another victim with the same
profile was discovered in another canal
within 18 months a further four dead
bodies were discovered
all of the same profile and all in the
same region
all were in the states of decomposition
and all were victims
of asphyxiation and even though the
jefferson davis parish police assembled
a task force to investigate
it wasn't long before an eighth body
arrived
in august 2009 it was now that the
police began to acknowledge that this
was the work
of a serial killer and the victim soon
became known
as the jeff davis however when author
and investigator ethan brown began to
look into the case
he found something perhaps even more
disturbing
what appeared to have been the work of a
serial killer
might actually be something more like a
cover-up
but a cover-up of what exactly all the
victims had served as police informants
and all had been terrified before they
vanished
with none of them able to rely on the
help of the police one member of the
sheriff's office
had been named a suspect by multiple
witnesses
he was said to cruise around town with
his wife
picking up prostitutes drugging them and
then bring them back to their
sex room despite this he was only
interviewed by the task force
once perhaps even more shocking
was the allegation that louisiana
congressman charles boustani had sex
with three of the victims in a seedy
hotel
owned by one of his representatives
although this allegation was met with a
lawsuit
it was dropped in late december and the
allegation
stands to this day
a truck owned by the chief investigator
was involved in the case
with witnesses saying they saw one of
the victims inside
but the vehicle was later scrubbed clean
of evidence
and the officer whistleblower involved
in bringing this information to light
was soon out of a job something was
clearly going on but to this day nothing
concrete about a serial killer or a
cover-up
has yet to come to light and whoever
committed the crimes
may still be at large
perhaps the most famous serial killer
who is still on the loose
is the zodiac killer active in the late
60s the zodiac killer was responsible
for the murders
of five people in northern california
and has since become one of the most
enigmatic and haunting serial killers in
history
not so much for the crimes themselves
which were incredibly violent
but for the unsettling interactions he
had with the police
and when you stand out among serial
killers in california
a state with a laundry list of infamous
serial killers
you know you're a bizarre individual
the five killings at first seemed random
but when the police and newspapers began
receiving strange letters from an
individual
claiming to be the killer it came clear
that a serial killer was involved
but here's the thing anyone could have
sent a prank letter claiming to be the
killer
these letters however were laden with
haunting symbols references to astrology
and
even to fiction the letters referred to
the fact that man
was the most dangerous game an obvious
nod to the short story in film from the
early 20th century
of the same name which later became the
inspiration for the 1987
movie predator one lesser even included
a piece of the victim's shirt
the killer's letters included a 408
symbol
cryptogram which was said to reveal his
identity but
when it was finally cracked it revealed
something
more sinister a misspelt message which
read
i like killing people because it is so
much fun it is more fun than killing
wild game in the forest
because man is the most dangerous animal
of all to kill
something gives me the most thrilling
experience it is even better than
getting your rocks off with a girl
the best part of it is that when i die i
will be reborn in paradise
and thee i have killed will become my
slaves
i will not give you my name because you
will try to slow down or stop
my collecting of slaves for my afterlife
creepy right of his victims
he killed two young lovers making out
after parking his car right beside
theirs
when the boyfriend got out of the car to
confront the mysterious visitor
he was shot dead the girlfriend was then
killed as she fled
her body was found eight meters from the
car
not long after he did the exact same
thing to another couple
with one of the victims surviving and
describing the zodiac killer
as a late 20s white male approximately
200 pounds with curly brown hair
later the zodiac attacked a couple
having a picnic on the shores of lake
berryessa
arriving dressed in a black outfit and
hud with a white circle and cross
painted on his chest
the zodiac held a couple at gunpoint
tied them both up then attempted to stab
them to death when he was done he went
to the victim's car
drew the circle and cross symbol on the
door and wrote
vallejo 12 20 68
74 69 september 27 2769
6 30 by 9. the zodiac then went to a
nearby pay phone
and informs the police once discovered
one of the victims survived and managed
to tell
everyone about this horrifying encounter
the letters abruptly stopped in 1974
but the zodiac killer was never caught
he has at least five victims to his name
and claimed to have killed over 37.
police have amassed over 2500 suspects
but even with dna testing and one man
claiming the zodiac killer was his
father
nothing has ever led to a breakthrough
and the chilling hunter of
men still remains at large thank you for
watching
if you enjoyed this video then please
consider supporting me on patreon
because it really helps me
to continue to make these videos the
links in the description
also you can get your hands on a first
edition signed copy of my new book
sticker flag in it
by heading on over to unbound publishing
the links in the description and
pre-ordering yours today
thank you